but speaking of the patriots and
quarterbacks peter there is news
boston globe
reporting
that the patriots and cam newton have
agreed to terms on a one-year deal so
one of the great mysteries two of the
great mysteries really of the looming
off-season are solved cam is off the
market and the patriots apparently have
their quarterback for 2021.
i'm a bit mystified by this but
you know it just it must come down to
the fact
that new england looks at its options
and says
hmm jimmy garoppolo do we really love
him enough
to make a huge trade for him no we
really don't
um we're drafting 15th
do we really love mac jones enough
to a risk that he'll be there at 15
or trade up to make sure we get him
or or any of the quarterbacks
and so i look at the patriots and i look
at this move and i said it's a pragmatic
move you know because i just saw this
too it's a pragmatic move because they
didn't think they could do better
well that's right they didn't think they
could do better and with the opportunity
of a full year
to work with cam newton maybe it will be
better the covet 19 issue he denied
having any type of brain fog but he's
later said that that illness affected
him throughout the course of the season
that derailed things at a time when they
were looking like they could move in the
right direction that this could work out
so
maybe a reset another chance another
opportunity and when you consider the
money that they have
and who knows what they're going to pay
cam newton they ended up getting him
last year peter for a final price when
you consider all the incentives per game
roster bonuses etc they got him for 3.7
million last year
i i don't know yet i haven't seen what
they're gonna pay him this year but
they've got the money to spend elsewhere
they were smart about the cap they're
one of the teams that wishes the cap was
lower because they planned for
a significant reduction in the salary
cap because of the pandemic they want it
lower for strategic reasons because it's
going to help them if it's lower they
still have the money to spend they put
some players around cam newton they were
seven and nine last year despite all of
the struggles they're not far away from
being a team that could be competitive
and relevant
and uh
playoff bound in 2021
and you know look this only happens if
bill belichick is sold
on cam newton
and you know what this does to me mike
this
says to cam newton
uh that hey one of the greatest coaches
in hit in the history of team sports
uh saw you have
to be charitable a mediocre year
in 2020
and then he thought enough of you
to want round two
you know to have a second year with cam
newton and you know the other thing that
this does mike
and so and so my point is that cam
newton must say
okay
i i am i'm playing for this guy and i'm
i'm gonna leave no stone unturned this
off season to be fantastic for this guy
but i'll tell you what else this does
mike
because the patriots obviously with you
know whatever they have 68 million
dollars according to over the cap
uh available under the cap cam obviously
is not going to take a lot of that
so what this does
is it says to the patriots okay now
you have such horrible weapons
you got terrible weapons now go get
kenny galladay and johnny smith
rebuild your wide receiver and tight end
rooms right now this year you want to be
a contender next year
go get those two guys or go get a really
good receiver and a really good tight
end because right now you do not have
weapons befitting
even a borderline playoff team
well but the patriots rarely go out and
spend right out of the gates in free
agency i recall two guys for whom they
paid market value adelius thomas in 2007
ish that didn't work out and then stefan
gilmore a few years ago when he left the
bills that did work out i think that
what the patriots will do instead like
they typically do
let the market soften and go out and buy
up a bunch of these guys we talked about
last hour who aren't going to be getting
big money and you convince them to come
to new england now new england doesn't
have
the shine that it once did
but it's still a place where you know
you're going to contend you're going to
compete you're going to you're going to
more likely than not be relevant and hey
there's a lot of guys in the nfl who
respect cam newton and a lot of guys in
the nfl who are going to want to play
with cam newton and that's going to help
them as well but i think the patriots
may be able to go out and bargain shop
like never before to round up guys who
can come in
and for a relatively low price for real
value you said last week when you know
when a gabe jackson is available you're
gonna you're gonna compare him to who
you have on the roster dollar for dollar
who can i get at a cheaper price and
you're gonna have some guys currently on
the team who think they're gonna be on
the team who aren't gonna be on the team
because they're gonna get supplanted by
one of these other guys who is a better
bargain when you look at the cap dollars
invested in getting that player
if the patriots do that mike then
to me
and and i don't deny that you're right
and i on the one hand
i hate this sort of
everybody
leaping out there to sign
this year's bright shiny object
more often than not
it ends up hurting your team
and i guess if the patriots do wait then
they wait for say
john brown and jared cook
you know instead of
sitting there right then and basically
saying we're gonna go shop at the top of
the market if they wait two weeks
then they go get guys either for one
year contracts who are good players
or you know maybe a two or three year
contract but guys who they don't view as
being permanent guys but just upgrades
over what they have right now it's going
to be interesting to see if belichick
breaks his own mold
you know there was a report one of the
sunday splash reports the final sunday
the regular season that newton and the
patriots were expected to part ways
belichick bristled at that
after their season ending game
and ever since then
we've gotten the indications cam
was willing to go back belichick
praising cam
and here it is i'm really not surprised
by it i'm surprised it happened
before cam got a chance to see what was
out there but you know what here's the
reality
he knows
what's out there when matt milano
resigned with the bills yesterday matt
milano wasn't getting the interest in
free agency i was told
recently that he thought he was going to
get that the market's already opened the
tampering has happened and
cam newton there's no way no way his
representation didn't call every other
team that's looking for a quarterback
and have the hypothetical conversation
about a certain hypothetical 2015 league
mvp who hypothetically is available to
any team that hypothetically is looking
for a quarterback so he knows what's out
there he knows what's behind every other
door before he takes what the patriots
are offering that's how they got to this
point before the market opened uh and uh
you know good for both sides to get it
done they know their certainty and now
they can focus on other positions and i
i was excited last year to see what cam
was going to do for new england when he
arrived on short notice this time around
he has maximum opportunity whatever off
season program they have maximum
opportunity to get ready second year in
the offense i like it i like it and i i
think that
the patriots will surprise people this
year and it's going to be the patriots
in cam newton hosting
the buccaneers and tom brady at some
point during the 2021 regular season
mike there's two other factors cam
newton going back to new england number
one because you really don't know if
he's your long-term guy
all of a sudden the patriots can sit
there with the 15th pick in the draft
and what happens
if young trey lance from north dakota
state is there at pick 15
what do they do
maybe they just take a long-term guy
because most nfl people believe that
trey lance probably needs a year of
seasoning or maybe two years of
seasoning after having a pretty
inexperienced
you know uh division one double a or fcs
whatever it's called
and and are
fbs i forget what that stuff is called
but the other thing that this does mike
is that it basically takes the new
england patriots
out of
the realm of to me
trading up and trying to get a great
quarterback in this draft trying to get
their dream quarterback
now you know that's one more team
that needed a quarterback that has its
question answered not to say that they
ever weren't going to be in position for
deshaun watson but it is just one more
team
that could convince
nick casario the longer i wait the fewer
candidates there are going to be
and trey lance's pro day workout happens
today they can wait until one of the
later rounds to get a guy that they can
quietly groom and develop that's
typically how they've done things even
brady if you haven't heard at some point
in the last 21 years was a low round
pick so you know when you go all in with
that first round quarterback
you're taking a chance especially if
you're giving up extra assets to trade
up and bill belichick is the kind of guy
who wants to have maximum lottery
tickets in the draft not go all in and
move up and obviously jared stidham may
be going the way of brian hoyer although
you keep stood him around he's entering
year three of a mid-round rookie deal
you can keep him around keep him in the
system have him as an emergency option
but also i think peter there's room
there if they move on from hoyer to have
a young guy who's on the depth chart who
quietly and diligently spends this year
learning the ropes and then maybe in a
year or two he can become the guy if
they get someone who develops the way
that a guy like tom brady developed 21
years ago not that lightning is ever
going to strike twice in the same
lifetime for the patriots but but that's
the model you get a guy who doesn't have
all the pressure and the expectation of
being a first-round pick
who still has some skills and you see
whether to what extent he can bring
those skills out
with a year or two on the bench
you know the one last thing i would say
about newton in the patriots is that
look
you know
belichick i think is really lucky right
now to have josh mcdaniels
as his sort of solid kind of aid to camp
and
you know it's not that that josh
mcdaniels is dictating what's going on
but this
signing tells me
that mcdaniels really liked cam and he
liked working with him and he was a
worker bee
so i think that the chemistry
had to have been good in the quarterback
room which you always heard it was
and with josh mcdaniels and i think
probably belichick and mcdaniels both
figure this is the best we can do to be
a competitive team this year
and so you know you worry about this
year this year
and then you worry about next year next
year so i think the patriots have always
done that
and this is a great example of we're not
really going to be totally focused you
know unless we get a quarterback who
falls in our lap at 15. we're not going
to be totally focused on this you know
on 2022.
all that matters is being as good as we
can be this year
greg bedard who was one of your charter
members at the monday morning
quarterback team back in 2013-ish did i
get the year right was it 2013. you did
yeah 2013.
uh i i shouldn't i shouldn't have asked
then i should have just kept going
anyway bedard recently said on his
podcast that
jimmy garoppolo was the plan a for the
for the patriots at quarterback this
year and it's possible that that was
still accurate it's possible they just
decided
we can't wait for the 49ers to get their
upgrade before they figure out what
they're going to do with garoppolo
because i believe the 49ers aren't going
to let that bird out of their hand until
they know they have someone better
whether it's trading for sam darnold
getting someone in the draft whatever
the patriots don't want to sit around
and wait because then cam newton's going
to be gone and this is why the advanced
tampering can be useful you get an idea
of what's out there what's not out there
and and i think this is the first
sign of why it's important even though
desean watson wasn't going to go to new
england russell wilson is not going to
go to new england this is what happens
when teams aren't going to wait around
because when you wait around
to go for
what may be your plan a if garoppolo was
if bedard was accurate and garoppolo was
the plan a
you sit around and wait for plan a you
lose plan b
and we're gonna see teams move to plan b
if they don't think they have a good
shot at plan a that could quite well be
what the patriots did
hey look greg really knows the patriots
so
i have full confidence in him when he
says that
um and i think the biggest thing with
garoppolo and what you're talking about
with the timing is absolutely correct
but there was another scenario
pointed out to me by somebody who knows
the 49ers quite well
trade the 43rd pick in the draft
to the jets and get sam darnold okay
and don't trade jimmy garoppolo
basically keep garoppolo around
and know that in essence the hot breath
of sam darnold is coming down his neck
and this is the year that we'll decide
if you're the long-term quarterback of
the san francisco 49ers or
if we move to darnold or someone else
because mike
everybody has always said well you know
if you get darnold you've gotta you know
you've got to guarantee that fifth year
and all that no you don't
you know
that can be
sam darnold is smart enough to know that
if they move away next year
from jimmy garoppolo he's smart enough
to know
i've died and gone to heaven if i could
work with kyle shanahan on a contending
team every year
and so
are you going to take the last dime in a
contract if you become a free agent not
saying you would maybe in december of
this year they'd go after him hard and
try to sign him but but anyway i'm
getting ahead of myself i'm just simply
saying that i do not think that trading
for sam darnold would automatically mean
end of days for jimmy garoppolo in san
francisco
here's the only problem with that
scenario
when as a practical matter the cap is
dropping
25 million
from where it was supposed to be it's
one thing to focus on the reduction of
15.7 but it had gone up by 10 million
every year since 2013 teams were
expecting another 10 million bump 208 is
what they were expecting it's 182.5
instead when you take a 25 million
dollar difference and throw on top of it
garoppolo making 25 million this year
that's too much to pay garoppolo if
they're gonna do that they need to
squeeze garoppolo to take less and
that's why last week i was intrigued by
the report that the 49ers had called the
panthers about teddy bridgewater because
bridgewater is due to make 17 million
this year and i thought maybe that was a
way
to subtly open the door to the reality
that the 49ers aren't going to pay
garoppolo 25 million this year because
let's face it peter if they would cut
him no one's paying him 25 million this
year not not for a guy that's missed 23
games more than he's won
over the past four years
yeah over the last three years um and
mike the other way to look at that story
is just simply to say that
you know because my belief is that kyle
shanahan still really likes garoppolo
but
the the
you know the realistic
part of this story
is that if he slips on a banana peel on
october 1st and he's out for the year
they can't rely on cj the cj beathards
of the world you know nick mullens you
can't rely on them anymore because they
have shown they're nice backup
quarterbacks nice but they're not
winning elements on a you know on a
playoff team
and like when the eagles had nick foles
they knew that they could win playoff
games with nick foles now he's not the
greatest quarterback in the world but
they knew that he was good enough to win
playoff games
and in san francisco that's one of the
reasons why i would go out and get on
his rookie contract one more year of sam
darnold and i would say hey listen i
can't tell what's going to happen at the
end of this year i really can't
but for now
having a garoppolo darnold combo platter
in a football sense not in a salary cap
sense but in a football sense really
makes you a better team
there's one wild card in san francisco
and i'm not suggesting that he's going
to get the job or he's going to do
enough to even stay on the roster but
they have josh rosen remember he was
content last year to be on the tampa bay
practice squad and then the opportunity
arose to go to san francisco and he
jumped at the chance to work with kyle
shanahan and in that system there's a
chance there's a chance they develop the
right relationship the right chemistry
and if rosen is smart enough to know
that the path to success in shanahan's
offense is to do exactly what shanahan
wants
every way every play every read every
step every throw if he can figure that
out and do it consistently he's got a
chance
to be the guy and that would be the
steal of all steals a top 10 quarterback
from 2018 that you get on the street and
you quietly groom behind the scenes into
a quarterback that can be the answer for
you over the long haul long way to go
before that happens but it just shows
you that shanahan has options he knows
how to work with quarterbacks and uh
bottom line is they're not ready to pull
the plug on garoppolo so the patriots
not
able to wait for garoppolo pivot to cam
newton he will be back with new england
according to now multiple reports newton
back to the patriots on a one-year deal
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports